[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren für den r8 fünf köpfe fünf
meinungen schön dass sie eingeschaltet
haben um einen diskussionsfreudigen
gäste auf die ich mich den ganzen tag
gefreut habe und dessen direkt damit
starten wir mit der vorstellung sind
heute abend nachtjournal erfinder und
moderator heiner bremer er gehört zu den
angesehensten und preisgekrönten
politikjournalisten dieser republik
schön dass sie da sind der bremer neben
ihnen der frühere fdp innenminister
gerhard baum für den krieg eine
schmerzhafte erinnerung ist erlebte als
zwölfjähriger die bombardierungen in
dresden schön dass sie heute hier sind
herr baum an meiner seite der spd
abgeordnete johannes er vor seiner die
bundeswehr tätig war von 2017 bis 2019
nahm er auch in acht einsätzen in
afghanistan und mali teil lars bender
ließ csu-politikerin jurist und
bundestagsabgeordneten dr silke laune
2013 promovierte sie mit einer arbeit
über das unterhaltsrecht weit sie heute
das erste mal nachschauen ich hoffe
natürlich nicht aber falls wir sind erst
einmal schauen jeder von uns hat ein
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt
schockiert woran er sich erfreut oder
was er einfach einmal mit anderen
menschen diskutieren möchte und mein
thema an diesem tag ist scholz hat zu
recht versagt olaf scholz wollte sie
karl lauterbach sowieso durch die
allgemeine impfpflicht ist heute in der
herzkammer der demokratie gescheitert es
ist für scholz ein politisches debakel
besonders schlimm am vormittag hatte er
extra seine außenministerin annalena
baerbock aus brüssel zurückbeordert
damit sie in berlin mit abstimmen kann
der kanzler wusste er braucht jede
stimme und er dachte er sich wohl im
pflicht wichtiger als nato treffen zum
ukraine krieg nun hat er verloren die
allgemeine impfpflicht ab 60 jahren wird
nicht kommen das muss für scholz ein
herber verlust sein ich finde zu recht
denn die allgemeine impfpflicht soll
auch nicht kommen die ab 60 nicht wie
heute entschieden wird und auch nicht
die ab 18 und ich bin jetzt sehr
gespannt wie meine gäste das sehen herr
bremer bei bild tv als gast zu sein das
hätte mich schon sehr überrascht wenn
scholz nicht gleich wieder passieren die
ohren kriegt und mit ihm die ganze ampel
aber ein bisschen ist ja daran würde
nicht so weit gehen dass er sozusagen
versagt hat es hat für mich zwei
institutionen
kein sehr gutes bild abgegeben das ist
einmal die ampelkoalition
die offenkundig bewiesen hat dass sie
keineswegs so stabil ist dass sie in
einer so wichtigen die menschen wirklich
interessieren den berührenden frage wie
ob nur die impfpflicht vielleicht dafür
sorgen kann das ist eine hoch impfquote
kriegen und damit nicht noch mal wieder
ein corona herbst mit lockdown
ausgangssperren und kontakt verboten
erleben sich offenkundig nicht zu einer
klaren haltung durchringen kann in einem
begriff von freiheit
den ich eher wo du liberalismus nennen
würde aber da kommen wir ja sicherlich
noch drauf zurück das ist ja alles dann
verfassungswidrig alle anderen eingriffe
waren es offenbar dann doch nicht also
habe ich meine probleme die fdp hat kein
gutes bild abgegeben die spd nicht klar
und in der tat haben sie recht warum vw
burg schön zu einer abstimmung kommt bei
der eigentlich klar das ist nicht auf
jede einzelne stimme ankam sondern
entweder man hätte eine mehrheit gehabt
oder man hat sie eben nicht gehabt uns
mal klar nicht gehabt da wäre glaubt die
nato konferenz wichtiger gewesen wenn
sie da geblieben wäre der zweite aber
was sie kritisch anmerken muss für mich
hat der bundestag versagt das parlament
hat versagt wenn man schon die
entscheidung über eine so wichtige frage
ins parlament delegiert was man
kritisieren kann aber was eigentlich
auch vorzüge hat dann muss ich doch
davon ausgehen dass die abgeordneten als
volksvertreter wirklich die interessen
des volkes im kopf haben und nicht in
parteitaktische interessen oder die
interessen von minderheiten und da hätte
ich mir nun schon gewünscht dass
jedenfalls in der nacht zu heute die
ampel und die cdu/csu noch mal
aufeinander zugegangen wenn jetzt haben
wir eine situation dass gar nichts ist
obwohl im prinzip beide vorschläge gar
nicht so weit auseinander waren für mich
zeigt das auch dass die cdu opposition
immer noch nicht richtig in der
opposition angekommen ist immer noch
nicht ganz verwunden hat dass die 16
jahre vorbei sind dass sie unbedingt
opposition um jeden preis machen sie
also insofern würde ich ihre these
relativieren da werde ich gleich mal was
letzte angriff war also ich kann sagen
ich hätte wahrscheinlich im dezember
letzten jahres die impfpflicht für alle
bekommen alle standen unter dem eindruck
der data variante die kliniken man
überlaufen der impfstoff hat gewirkt es
waren nachweislich wir haben ja nicht
nur allgemein sagen ich recherchiert ist
immer noch mal bei meinem eigenen
krankenhauses cook stimmt das was so
erzählt wird und da war ganz klar dass
vieles hat zugenommen schwere patienten
auf der intensivstation und absolute
mehrheit wirklich waren die ungeimpften
und in dieser situation hätte die ampel
ganz viel unterstützung aus union
bekommen hätte nein nein ich will es mit
lassen sie sich nicht weiter ausreden
warum ich glaube das hat sich wirklich
geändert deshalb ist der vorwurf auch
nicht gerechtfertigt das hat sich total
geändert durch omikron
allem auch die klinik schauen sie sich
an alle möglichen dreifach also doppelt
gm plus gepostet stecken sich inzwischen
mit omikron an ein es hat wirklich da
muss ich sagen es gibt auch keine
bundesverfassungsgerichts entscheidung
zur uni kommen und ich bin mir auch
ziemlich sicher dass die anders
ausgefallen
unmittelbar betroffen ich bin fast 90
ich trage einer maske ich gehe einkaufen
alle tragen masken künftig tragen sie
das nicht mehr
ich bin dem risiko egoistischer
ungeimpfte ausgesetzt die sich auf
kosten der allgemeinheit
praktisch einer sogenannte freiheit
erkaufen ich fühle mich ungeschützter
jetzt und die krankheitsverläufe die ich
meiner umgebung habe sind sehr
schwerwiegend die leute es gibt leute
die sehr schwer erkranken und im
verfassung steht drinnen wir haben die
gesundheit der menschen zu schon zwei
steht drin halle es gibt ja auch
langweilig unversehrtheit ist in der
verfassung stehen halt alle grundrechte
die betroffen sind und es ist es eine
geduckt recht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit die die nicht geimpft
werden von unterschätzen sie das nicht
wie stark die das als eingriff empfinden
es gibt es recht der freiheit angst vor
lockdown auch recht auf eingeübten
ausgeübten gewerbebetrieb dass wir
natürlich haben bei den geschäftskunden
es gibt sie wissen doch sie sind auch
jurist eine verfassung ist ein ausgleich
zu in den verschiedenen grundrechten und
wir haben jetzt mit ronny kommt keinen
nachweis mehr dass wir dadurch ist zu
einer deutlichen verbesserung zu
deutlich mehr schutz die ssd zwei masten
pflicht hier wird abgeschafft das ist
eine sehr hochgradige schutz folgen ob
sie wisse was
ungefähr halbiert ein direct x reihe
nach wir wollen eine einstellung und zu
sagen das bestimmt die chance für eine
für eine allgemeine impfpflicht im
dezember besser gewesen wäre übrigens
der kanzlerin aber als die diskussion
wird genau aber herr bremer sie müssen
ja auch sagen wir haben in der
ampelkoalition diese debatte wie wir die
korona handeln und die ganzen maßnahmen
verändert haben die ins parlament geholt
vorwurfsvoll bundesregierung gemacht
habe das parlament geholten das breit
diskutiert und ich finde es auch noch
stärker zu sagen ist der kanzler sagt er
ist in so einer frage mit diskutant und
die abgeordneten als gewählte
volksvertreter finden sich in gruppen
zusammen mit verschiedenen lösungen
verschiedenen ansätzen und diskutieren
das in der herzkammer der demokratie an
der stelle als repräsentative vertreter
der bevölkerung das finde ich eine
riesige stärke dieses verfahrens das ist
nicht von einer regierungspolitik und
vorgenommen dass gerade hier sehr
kritisiert dass damals das nicht als
regierungsvorlage gemacht worden ist er
finde ich jetzt auch schnee von gestern
jetzt mich stört an der argumentation
von frau lagarde folgendes damals hätte
man eine mehr gekriegt weil ja immer
noch die data variante da war bionicon
nicht wenn das heißt für mich im
umkehrschluss wir reden wieder über eine
impfpflicht wenn wir eine ganz
gefährliche mutation haben nur wenn die
mutation da ist dann ist jede
impfpflicht zu spät aber jeweils an doch
mein vorschlag gemacht der genauen
beiden lösungen vorsieht harry einmal
ganz jetzt den vorschlag beschreiben
denn die union gemarkung die zuschauer
dieses recht nicht mit loca es geht
darum dass wir jetzt schon die
voraussetzungen schaffen für eine
impfpflicht
aber auch mit mit einem im register
alles vorplanen dass wenn es wirklich
wir wissen ja nicht was im herbst kommt
und ich muss ihnen doch nicht sagen
grundrechtseingriff auf vorrat ist nur
verfassungsrechtlich nicht möglich wenn
die absoluten deutlich stärkere durch
einen dauerhaft der gleichen härte
aufkommen fast so werden wir wieder eine
delta oder eine ähnlich starke variante
haben die wieder zu schweren verläufen
führt die zur überlastung der kliniken
führen und wir einen wirksamen impfstoff
haben dann kann diese impfung scharf
geschaltet werden natürlich durch einen
nochmaligen bundestagsbeschluss
erfolgsfall wäre ja nicht bis ich alle
menschen geimpft ist diese neue welle
voll aber die brauchen nachdem grundlage
dass dies unmöglich zu sagen dass dieser
grundrechtseingriff verhältnismäßig
geeignet erforderlich und
verhältnismäßig im engeren sinne also
angemessen ist im hinblick auf den
legitimen zweck von der c
junioren die verfassung
und recht sein das ist nun brechen
der gesetzgeber hat leben und gesundheit
zu schützen und nicht im vordergrund die
geschäfte und die gastwirtschaften und
aus ist es sind auch lieber jeden alle
beschwerden in karlsruhe sind
gescheitert herr buschmann ist der baum
darf ich ihnen noch eine frage stelle
ich sitze jetzt neben ihnen und ich fand
es eben sehr bewegend für sie gesagt
haben sie sind fast 90 und natürlich
gehören sie zur risikogruppe ich bin
gebucht hat aber ich kann sie doch
genauso ansteckend können sie sich denn
überhaupt neben jetzt sitzen sicher
fühlen weil ich den ich kann den jungs
ja auch übertragen obwohl ich gewusst
ich möchte mich anstecken was sie wollen
dass ich immer noch den stücken
können
hättest denn was was ist das für eine
einschränkung dass man in bestimmten
situation eine maske trägt die last der
das oft stößt auf große akzeptanz weil
es ja und vielleicht die koalition will
sitzen nicht mehr aber wir haben auch
nichts gegen die masken pflicht aber die
impfpflicht ist das
verfassungsrechtliche probleme also die
im flur land ist ja das müssen wir mal
verschiedene probleme sprechen jetzt
einfach verfassung die these wonach
verfassungsrecht und ich bin auch
gelernter jurist und zwar mit beiden ex
amt dann freue ich mich jetzt auf die
these von freiland weil ich glaube das
könnte jetzt ein spannender kampf werden
zwischen den beiden juristen ja also ich
gebe zu ich bin da wirklich irgendwie
enttäuscht weil wie gesagt es hätte
schon mal eine chance gegeben auch aus
parteitaktischen gründen hat man dann
diese frage aber gemachten noch mehrere
das verfahren aber parteitaktik das und
dann ich sag ich das endgültig
abstimmungsverhalten der parteitaktik
der ampel
da hab ich jetzt will ich gar nicht mal
so vor waffen aber dann kriegt man es
nicht zustande und was ist dann das
ergebnis wir haben im plenum nur gehört
die union die schuld wissen sie wenn die
fdp oder viele das recht haben zu sagen
wir halten es für verfassungswidrig
stimmen nicht zu dann hat auch die union
des rechens ragen dosen fdp hat die fdp
die fdp viele fdp wähler sagen das könnt
ihr mir eigentlich glauben
die fdp
hat schon mit
verantwortungsbewusstsein zeigen dass
der märz sagte schadenfreudig wenn er
keine mal gehör verschaffen und es ist
die regierung das
war schon sehr sehr schade dass die
union nicht an den erträgen beteiligt er
sich an dem prozess beteiligen können
und herwig decker und zwei weitere
kollegen aus der union haben ja auch für
den regierung oder den entwurf der
gruppe wie sie gestimmt aber ich kann
ihnen sagen das hat sich geändert am
anfang gab es streit die hälfte wollte
keine impfpflicht in der union die
andere war dafür hab ich
von geändert weil sie haben es
eigentlich genau richtig gesehen weil es
nicht geeignet ist und auch nicht
erforderlich gibt mildere mittel die
masken pflicht hochwirksam gp2 ist ein
milderes mittel dann wir haben die
situation per mikro wirklich dass wir
keine überlastung der kliniken haben
jetzt kommt das argument es gibt
geimpftes personal inzwischen die auch
krank werden durch omikron und deshalb
haben wir aktuell zum teil in einigen
kliniken ein problem wieder aber die
sind geimpft das heißt wenn ich alle im
warum die geimpften gebe es auch weiter
das ist die besonderheit bei obi sterben
täglich über 200 menschen ja aber was
haben ja wir haben omikron ist im moment
ungefähr vergleichbar wie eine normale
grippe lieber vor drei jahren auch
hatten demonstriert anlage älter aber
die todeszahlen sind ungefähr so und ich
muss jetzt mal ehrlich sagen wir können
nicht die ideen jetzt ungeimpft sind die
haben eigenverantwortung sozusagen aber
die ditib sind gebe es trotzdem weiter
sie müssen trotzdem nicht zwischen
rettet mit meinem mann möchte nochmals
projekt einbringen wir haben ja fast
kein land in europa nimmt eine
impfpflicht gibt ja ich habe auch gegen
die impfpflicht heute gestimmt dass ich
habe keinen antrag befürwortet weil ich
keinen antrag als geeignet erachtet habe
dass er das problem löst in der form
dass auch umsetzbar ist also keine gegen
inter perfekt stellt nein ich habe mich
und ich habe nein ich habe mich nicht
gegen meinen bundeskanzler gestellt ich
habe dem antrag der wiese behrens nicht
zugestimmt ja ich hätte dem antrag der
von professor mühlmann zugestimmt den 17
vergab weil ich den mechanismus trotz
aller schwächen im antrag noch am
überzeugendsten fand den gab ist nicht
mehr seit gestern und darum habe ich
dann keinen antrag zugestimmt und der
bundeskanzler hat sehr lange diskutiert
das mit an eine persönliche auffassung
und macht das nicht als bundeskanzler
also ich habe zwei dinge gelernt das ist
das richtige mittel ist die korona sache
zu bekämpfen die maske dann frage ich
hier im ernst warum sie in der ganzen
regierung seit alle möglichen von
ausgangssperren bis zu kontakt verboten
gemacht haben wenn es eigentlich doch
nur auf die maske ankommt der nein nein
nein die macher haben sperren an aber
wir
starten also weiter was ich schon gerne
wir wirklich sagen der impfpflicht gibt
es nur noch dann wenn ich damit das
virus ausrottet dann werden wir nie
weiterkommen es ist ein fortschritt wenn
ich dafür sorgen kann dass jedenfalls
die geimpften stark geschützt sind das
nicht ungeimpfte aus blankem egoismus
und sturheit die anderen in einer
geiselhaft nehmen und ein letzter satz
verlorene 1 habe ich im verfassungsrecht
gelernt auch artikel 2 absatz 2 die
körperliche unversehrtheit ist kein
super grundrecht als
unantastbares nicht monat aussage
christen ein starkes
grundregeln höchstwert in der es nicht
und antara roth insofern hätte man
fliegt sehr wohl verfassungsfest machen
können und wenn ich das urteil das
gericht zu den zur bundes notbremse
richtig seht das zeigt dass sehr viel
spielraum da ist ich glaube nicht dass
ein verfassungsgericht das geändert
hätte oder aufgaben ein die hard bank
die haben eine chance verpasst hier auf
die kohletitel gegangen verpassen wir in
unserem antrag jetzt in der mehrheit
kapverden aber so bereiten wir regieren
haben gruppen fachmann nicht beteiligt
haben sich im
streit
aktive politik also ein gutes bild
deutsche politik nicht dann halt nicht
die welt durchlebt in flammen und wir
können uns nicht einmal auf eine
schutzmaßnahme wie sie auch ist einigen
ich meine man ich hätte erwartet ich war
an zwei kabinetten dass ein kabinett
zunächst einmal wirklich ernsthaft
versucht eine eigene meinung zu bilden
und dann auch die durchsetzt in der
koalition muss jeder mal nachgeben auch
herr buschmann
aber herr bauen ist es nicht ist es
überhaupt noch eine frage der partei
oder nicht eher eine gewissensfrage ich
noch da könnte doch alles zur
gewissensfrage machen jeder bundesrat
eine gewissensfrage aber es geht
wirklich nicht so nicht sehen wer mir
andere fragen wenn es um sterbehilfe
geht wenn es einen gentechnologie jedes
jahr geben lagen gewesen da geht es um
einen schwerwiegenden körperlichen
eingriff in die grundrechte und den kann
man durchaus als ethische frage sehen
die jährigen sich selber bewerten muss
und das haben wir heute getan wir haben
heute eine debatte geführt die
sicherlich teilweise sehr lebhaft war
aber die auch genau das abgebildete was
auf den straßen in den gastwirtschaften
überall in unserer gesellschaft geführt
wird seit wochen monaten naja die hand
bekommen wofür bekommen dabei tausende
e-mails an hat
dann ist es zu spät so lange dieser
hätten die wenigsten die vorbereitung
machen können hier weil er das haus und
dem herner ev ger auf gehören dann
müsste die impfzentren vorhalten über
den sommer das ist eigentlich das haben
wir einen war noch vorgesehen hätten sie
ja zustimmen kann
der gorilla ist die auch bei der fdp bei
kubicki deutsche pärchen und anderen vor
gekommene meinung wir brauchen das gar
nicht es gibt ganz andere mittel und
nicht die masse sondern anreize damit
kriegen wir zum impfen seit einem
dreiviertel jahr funktioniert das nicht
nein und der zweite punkt den ich noch
loswerden wollte harald der verweis auf
andere länder ist irreführend ihr habt
keine impfpflicht aber sie haben eine
impfquote free teilweise 90 prozent für
ausgleichende länder wie spanien italien
wo wir immer sagen würden
hat immer den sonderweg der
nur sagen es liegen inzwischen auch
geimpfte dort ist kaum leute auf den
intensivsten es liegen viele andere aber
es ist nicht so dass die schweren
verläufe so extrem voll sind deswegen
sind die kliniken nicht voll ich muss
ergänzen wäre es um wer sich nicht
impfen lassen will hat dann das risiko
dass er auch einen schweren verlauf hat
und die ganzen und windows 7 auch eben
im moment omikron weiter und deshalb ist
dieses 20 in für alle und dann ist das
problem gelöst so wie wir es im herbst
viele dachten dieses ist jetzt mit nikon
sony lassen sie mich noch mal ergänzen
in bremen sieht man ja an der basis
immunisierung was eine
zielgruppengerechte ansprache ich finde
wir haben noch nicht alles getan
bevölkerung gerade auch migrantische
hintergründe bevölkerung zu einem
hintergrund zu informieren in deren
sprachen das bringt jede menge haben
noch jede menge potenzial was
herausholen kann und ich glaube da haben
wir nach unglückseligen herr lauterbach
nicht links was eingefangen das doch
eure aufgabe ihr regiert ja seit drei
monaten
einen gedankengang reinbringen und zwar
eben auch schon drin hat und ich möchte
ihn nochmal auf nachfragen bei beerbaum
beim bremer die geimpften geben ist ja
auch weiter das ist das nämlich so sehr
gegen die impfpflicht spricht also
inwiefern kann man den risikogruppen
schützen wenn man auch ansteckendes und
den virus weiter gibt also da spricht
auch komplett gegen eine impfpflicht
also wir wissen doch dass das
weitergeben durch gifte oder auch an
geimpfte meist zu ganz milden verläufen
führt was wir verhindern wollen ist doch
im grunde dass wir weiter eine mehrere
millionen 14 millionen haben die
ungeimpft durch die gegend laufen und
wenn sie infiziert werden auf der
intensivstation oder auf dem totenbett
land das kann man dadurch verhindern
dass man sie zu ihrem glück ein wenig
zwingt
so will war betreuungs richterin das
muss jetzt doch mal sagen und leider
leider da haben sie in gewisser weise
recht es wäre sinnvoll sie zum glück
vielleicht zu zwingen aber das dürfen
wir eben nicht verfassungsrechtlich habe
ich jetzt brachen sie ein recht sogar
marco zu saufen es tut mir leid so
drastisch zu sagen und jetzt inzwischen
die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auch zur
sterbehilfe und sie wissen dass wir im
grunde faktisch jetzt auch ein ein
rechtsfuß selbsttötung haben bilder
kontrolle johannes sagen das stimmt
nicht wir müssen die gegen ihren willen
mit aller macht zwingen es wäre sinnvoll
wenn man sich weniger an steckt wenn das
mal weniger weitergibt das haben wir mit
omikron so nicht aber ich habe ein recht
die leute zu zwingen zum selbstschutz es
ist nicht mehr die
verlage impfen lassen warum damals
dachte ich würde mich auch jetzt impfen
lassen so wenig ich will es auch nicht
die virologen sagen doch bei den
ungeimpften entstehen die mutation
natürlich verlangt ich habe organ hat in
die ritze dass jeder das recht hat sich
selbst zu schädigen sich selbst
gefertigten aber er hat nicht das recht
andere zu belästigen zu gefährden zudem
krank zu machen indem er seine infektion
weiter trägt das ist doch klar wie green
tragen ist doch auch weit aber doch
wohl nicht mehr sehen folgen
hat sich verändert also ich für den
haben sie haben sie heute die zeitung
gelesen es gibt ja rieslings über den
längst forschung wonach wir einen ganz
andere nämlich eine kombination von
delta und auch mikron zu erwarten haben
unser museum haben darüber haben zudem
vertreten wir haben die pflicht also
lassen wir doch die frage kommen wir
lassen den funken bei herr bremer
leben jetzt weiter weil eine sache die
hat herr baum auch schon angesprochen
und die ist selbstverständlich auch so
es gibt auch noch andere sachen über
dieses zu diskutieren lohnt und was
eigentlich gerade auch wirklich wichtig
ist als nur die irgend schlicht vor
allem gibt es auch noch andere themen
und herr bremer an uns heute auch ein
thema mitgebracht und da geht es
eigentlich um die atomkraft also ich
will dieses mal relativ kurze machen
damit wir uns dann auch richtig schöne
streiten können was mich seit einiger
zeit ärgert ist die tabuisierung eines
themas alles anderes her inzwischen kein
tabu mehr weder die bundeswehr
ausrüstung dringend überfällig viel zu
lange verschlampt worden von einer
großen koalition
auch ein tabuthema das so langsam fällt
ist dass man immer mehr klimaschutz
machen muss was ja im kern auch richtig
ist nur wenn ich den ukraine konflikt zu
ihr wenn ich sehe dass wir im grunde
entweder selbst ein energie embargo
machen müssen weil wir so unter druck
geraten dass das die anderen von uns als
beweis von solidarität fordern oder aber
der herr im kreml einfach mal sagt lasst
mich doch nicht von den western ihr tier
vorführen es drehe ich den geldhahn zu
dann haben wir probleme mit der
energieversorgung
in einer solchen situation
einfach zu sagen wir diskutieren über
alles auch über eine verlängerung der
laufzeiten für kohlekraftwerke
aber überhaupt nicht über eine
verlängerung der laufzeit dieser letzten
drei atommeiler vielleicht auch noch
eine wiederbelebung der gerade ende des
jahres stillgelegt meiner weil wir die
stromversorgung und dafür gilt ja nur
die kernenergie dadurch deutlich
absichern kann das was wir dann noch an
kohle und gas brauchen halt in die
anderen prozesse zu machen ich weiß auch
mit kernenergie kann ich kein auto
fahren und ich kann auch meine heizung
nicht betreiben aber ich kann die
stromversorgung weitgehend sichern über
das maß hinaus und muss nicht umschalten
jetzt kommt das argument kenne ich auch
brennelemente
also selbst und wenn die mode der stelle
wir kriegen die nicht so schnell die
neuen die man braucht selbst wenn man
jetzt sagt okay dann drosseln wir
die nutzung der kernenergie im sommer
und ersetzen das durch kohle dann habe
ich ja immer noch die chance dass ich in
dem winter wo es drauf ankommt wo jeder
merkt wenn es kalt wird in der wohnung
und wo ich keinen strom mehr hat um
irgendwas in lotte nicht zu haben und
dergleichen dann kann ich das nutzen
ganz abgesehen davon dass ich ohnehin
glaube dass man sehr wohl brennelemente
besorgen kann wenn man es denn will und
die politik es weh wenn die etwas will
kann sie ja anderes sehr deutlich machen
mich ärgert dass darüber nicht
diskutiert wird weil es einen grünen dna
ist und man wohl die sorge hat mein gott
den grünen wird jetzt schon so viel
zugemutet da kann man ihn als es geht um
mich nicht misszuverstehen nicht darum
dass die nächsten zehn jahre atommeiler
laufen es geht mir um diese
überbrückungszeit in der jetzigen durch
den ukraine krieg und die
unberechenbarkeit von wladimir putin
entstandene situation und da freilich zu
sagen das brauchen wir nicht halte ich
für leichtfertig ja ich habe einen
gewissen stolz dass die leute sie haben
nämlich damals genehmigt die drei die
sie jetzt genannt haben habe ich mit
meiner unterschrift genehmigt und ich
habe damals
meinen freund genscher der
parteivorsitzende mal gefragt kann ich
das macht meine fachleute
reaktorsicherheit im innenministerium
haben sehr sorgfältig das vorbereitet
ist ein konvoi sind nach einem gleichen
baumuster genehmigt und wird jede
schraube genehmigt so also ganz und da
hat er mir gesagt herr baum wenn sie das
nicht können dann müssen sie alle
laufenden atommeiler sofort abstellen
denn die die sie jetzt auf dem tisch
haben zur genehmigung sind noch
wesentlich sicherer als die verloren
also sie sind alle sich aber im grunde
müssen sie jetzt sich fragen steigen sie
aus da wenn sie nicht wohl wenn sie das
nicht wollen steigen sie aus der
atomenergie aus und ich kann jetzt nicht
sagen wie man die jetzt wieder
ertüchtigen kann was ich damals nur
bedauert habe dass wir aus der ganzen
technologie ausgestattet und drückt ja
mehr die ganze technologie geht darüber
hinweg da sind wir ausgestiegen in einer
paniksituation
ich habe mir große anstrengungen
unternommen die entsorgung
sicherzustellen die bis heute nicht
sichergestellt ich habe dieser tage mal
eine regierungserklärung nachgelesen
sich 1979 abgegeben habe da habe ich an
die länder appelliert doch ein endlager
zur führung der einzige der das gemacht
hat bei albrecht ist auf die schnauze
gebratenen fisch mit gordon mit gorleben
dann sind wir nach bayern unsere augen
sich nach bayern gerichtet keiner wollte
das bis heute der einzige der das mal
ehrlich angesprochen saerbeck das gehört
nämlich auch dazu und das obszöne an der
ganzen sache ist in kuba in zeiten der
knappheit kaufen wir atomstrom von
nachbarn also wir haben den ausstieg
falsch organisiert würde ich mal sagen
und mir die ganze klimageschichte hängt
ja daran dass wir gas kraftwerke bauen
im übergang und das finden und tracy ist
jetzt ins wasser gefallen und jetzt
steht man da und sah man wer in die
ganze mühe den ganze transformation
klimaneutralität hängt an um an den
gaskraftwerke müssen neu gebaut werden
aber dann ist mir das ganz auch kriegen
wenn die russen und die haben alles
vorbei dann ist es vorbei dann gehen wir
auch in polen gab er gebiet pervers ist
es eigentlich ausgerechnet von den
grünen dann die kohlekraftwerke
wieder zu reaktivieren oder die jetzigen
einfach laufen zu lassen wenn man doch
so awo und dem klimaschutz so hoch hält
den co2 ausstoß mal ich muss mir neu
dass ein atommeiler co2 ausscheiden ist
das tun die kohlekraft
darüber nicht gesprochen wird ist völlig
falsch wenn sie mal geschaut haben auf
der tagesordnung parlament es gab in den
letzten wochen verschiedenste anträgen
zu dem thema an ausschüssen wird das so
diskutiert das thema wurden durchaus
diskutiert und behandelten wird aber
haben wir haben die seite die mehrheit
eine liste ein thema mit dem uran das
haben sie selber anderes braucht mit den
brennstäben das zweite thema ist die
sicherheit also alle
sicherheitsgenehmigungen für die atom
laufwerke auslaufen aus grund ist die
letzten fünf jahre nicht investiert
worden es müsse erst mal investiert
werden dann müssen eine neue abnahme
erfolgen denn ich glaube aber wir
brauchen sicherheit esprit ohne
abgenommene sicherheitsrat wenn
man muss es nachts wenn das nicht ein
offenes und auch der müll jetzt mal ich
muss sagen wir sorgfältig prüfen ich
freue mich ja prima dass sie das so
ansprechen weil ja es ist irgendwo sind
trotzdem noch so ein bisschen tabu auch
in der medialen darstellung aber in
einer solchen krisensituation wo die
preise für energie explodieren und die
bürger sie quasi nicht mehr zahlen und
die leute in den ratschlag geben ihr
sollt frieren und sowas da kann es doch
nicht sein dass wird die dies lauf und
funktionieren dass man nicht in der lage
ist und die betreiber haben es
inzwischen ja auch einige dass es geht
dass man neue sicherheitskontrollen
macht und wenn es geht ihnen auch mal
drei vier jahre laufen lässt
nach hoya aber wir haben wir
festgestellt haben moderne des jahres
ist ja wohl dass ich endlich getätigt
wenn die
bremer ja ich wollte dir nur sagen ja
heute ich habe ein ganz tolles gefühl
dass bei diesem beispiel auch bei
anderen dinge die man eigentlich
politisch nicht so gern will
ausdrücklich darauf irgendwen in diesem
fall also auf die grünen und die deshalb
tabuisiert ist da bestreitet man die
tabuisierung und sagt wir diskutieren
das ja in ausschüssen und das geht da
auch hin und her und dann kommt
plötzlich die ganzen gegenargumente und
das thema ist wieder weg sie diskutieren
es nicht mit dem ziel es möglich zum
genannt möglichst unmöglich zu machen
und das ist eine unfassbare haltung bei
einem thema das jetzt unter den nägeln
brennt wollen sie verantworten glauben
sie wirklich dass die deutschen alle
noch so toll dafür sind dass wir alles
mögliche für die ukraine machen wenn sie
das in den nächsten winter keinen strom
gehabt also erstmal erst mal herr bremer
haben ein riesiges entlastung zwei
riesige entlastungspaket das gegentor
bekommen und die erstmal die bevölkerung
entlasten weil er hat ja ich wohne
preise als auch reicht nicht da ist
sicher auch finanziell in unter zwei
jahren schimpfen hause und erweitert
wurde dass wir eine riesige chance haben
jetzt die energiewende voranzubringen
jetzt mit dem früher so im sommer und im
herbst paket wirklich den klimawandel
mit windenergie mit pv energie voran zu
bringen und dort wesentlich unabhängiger
zu werden und wesentlich ambitionierter
voranschreiten zu können aber als je
geplant hatten ich möchte eine brauchen
wir keine art magischer gerne stellen
ein herr baum und zwar dass tabuthemen
wie jetzt hier schon aufgebrochen aber
wer ist eigentlich zu grün wenn man erst
mal so ausdrücken will die presse oder
die politik also wie kommt denn
eigentlich diese entwicklung deutet ja
also ich habe eben hat der bremer ja die
kritiker kritisiert der ganzen letzten
jahre und so das hat jemand anders
reagiert also ich bitte die
öffentlichkeit auch mal sich an die
eigene nase zu fassen wo wann die themen
ja zb in bayern lese ich da werden keine
überlandleitung genehmigt seit jahren
nicht sie kriegen den windstrom nicht
von norden und dass das eher weil die
bevölkerung dagegen es wir sind in
nordrhein westfalen beispielsweise
zugepflastert mit diesen dingern sie
also und es gibt jetzt ist eine
augenblick situation wo sich die markt
wo die meinung kippen aber die
öffentliche meinung die meinung die auch
angestoßen werden müsste von den medien
war auch nicht da wo war denn die
diskussion über die atomenergie vorher
ist ja jetzt auch nicht
wenn sie sagen ich möchte eine
zielorientierte politik ich gehe aber
ich bin bei ihnen wenn sie sagen so
einfach ist das nicht ein kernkraftwerk
mit einer neuen genehmigung zu versehen
ich das wird ganz schwierig aber es ist
nicht ausgeschlossen möglicherweise wird
geprägt wenn man will kann man eine
menge erreicht
ja aber nicht in sicht es reicht ja wenn
das bis ende des jahres im griff haben
denn da laufen die letzten erst aus noch
antworten kann also will sie den leuten
sagen wenn so ein ding in die luft geht
dann werden sich alle zurückschrecken
uns werden sagen nee nee dann lieber
nicht
wir haben die damals genehmigt weil sie
wussten die deutschen meiler sind mit
die sichersten nämlich teilweise aus
starb sie heute noch so sind nicht neu
als ich nicht für uns ist kein tsunami
bei uns dass kein fukushima das war ein
stimmungs entscheidung dieser koalition
mann der auch leider die fdp beteiligt
war nämlich mit guido westerwelle eine
der unglücklichen entscheidung die da
getroffen worden sind das war falsch
aber zu haben
der zweite wunde punkt die nicht
feststellen bei der diskussion der ampel
ich habe nicht nur den eindruck das war
dann gesagt wird wir diskutieren aber
wir diskutieren so dass etwas gar nicht
stattfinden kann ich habe auch den
eindruck dass man jetzt zunehmend den
ukraine konflikten die damit verbundenen
energie sorgen die wir haben nutzt um
sagen und jetzt muss man noch schneller
in die energiewende betreiben den
klimawandel vorantreiben
nur in dem oster paket von herrn habeck
steht eine zielsetzung für die
vollversorgung mit ökostrom
20 33 im koalitionsvertrag die navi
nämlich gelesen steht 20 45 jetzt hat
die ampel sich geeinigt das ding kommt
ein bundestag ist es wie jetzt beim
impfen jetzt soll der bundestag die lage
so wir wollten weil die ampel digital
controls was my last fahren die roten
co2 neutral in deutschland bis 2045 sein
und bis 2035 soll der strom eine
stimulation vertrauen so harald bitte
lesen vielleicht kurz ergänzt wir finden
das ja auch gut finden wenn wir gewisse
durch äußere umstände der druck wächst
und das beschleunigt aber die königs
halt nicht wenn sie brauchen wir die
heizungen austauschen sie kriegen doch
im moment kann ich aus eigener erfahrung
sagen in dem jahr gibt's keinen der mir
bereitet sie habe ungefähr zehn
angefragt in dem jahr gibt's keinen der
bereit ist die heizung auszutauschen die
handwerker sind völlig überlastet die
leute wollen man kann diese krise so
bitter es ist
sozusagen nutzen für eine anstehende
transformation aber sie werden ist nicht
von heute auf morgen hinkriegen da haben
sie einfach die handwerker nicht es
dauert mehrere jahre und deshalb wäre
dieser vorschlag gewesen ja jetzt in der
tinte als man muss ja wirklich sagen wir
sitzen ja jetzt gerade energiepolitisch
absolut in der tinte und es waren ja
auch schon verbände vor blackouts also
ich bin da ehrlich gesagt beim bremer da
muss man doch jetzt alles möglich machen
was irgendwie auch unsere co2 budget ja
ja was wir jetzt in die luft geben
bleibt ewig da über unser leben hinaus
also wenn wir jetzt verantwortungsvoll
handeln müssen haben wir nur noch einen
spieler habe ich auch lange gebraucht um
das zu begreifen also das heißt wir
müssen die transformation schaffen auch
jetzt unter erschwerten bedingungen und
wir müssen den krieg schaffen der kostet
ja wird und sehr viel kosten werden in
eine werden wir eine enge kam auch mit
unseren lebenshaltung wir werden
wohlstandsverlust haben das muss schon
gesagt werden das sind jahrhundert
aufgaben die klimageschichte ist eine
jahrhundertaufgabe
und ich also herr bremer ich hab das
nicht im einzel studiert aber was der
hupac daten ziel vorlegte ist meines
erachtens nicht unbedingt denn er
blendet doch die ökonomische
notwendigkeit die den damit verbunden
sein muss und auch die sozialen aspekte
nicht aus sie wird im reichen als und
reicht doch wenn die wendigkeit in
wirklichkeit also es gibt nachteile im
südlichen polen mit dem schluss doch
auch ich habe ja gesagt wir unterstützen
den transformationsprozess nur wir
werden ihn halt nicht von heute auf
morgen schnitt lösen
das paket ist eine familie mit zwei
kindern 800 euro eine 800 euro
erleichterung davon für zwei
arbeitnehmer und zwei kinder also
zweimal 300 und 200 euro
letzte woche war es ja jetzt vorher für
4500 liter waren es vorher 25 ist jetzt
für 1500 2000 euro wissen sie was ich
meine verdreifachung des öltanks
familien haben auch oft alte häuser da
gibt es oft noch eine ölheizung also
nicht das nicht so
wir können als stadt nicht alle krisen
dieser welt querfinanzieren wir können
den schock empfangen dem schock dieser
preissteigerung das müssen
leute weniger
also ich weiß was es heißt wenn leute
wenig geld haben dann sind die meisten
meiner wähler und da bin ich auch sehr
hinterher dass da auch was getan wird
und dann bin ich auch sehr froh dass wir
die drei monate sprit ermäßigungen
tankstelle erreicht haben über die
senkung der mineralölsteuer auf das eu
minimum aber wir können das nicht auf
die dauer finanzieren wenn sie sagen
immer mehr mehr mehr wir brauchen noch
mehr entlastungen sie wissen ganz genau
so etwas im haushalt die spieler für
mich sind das ist nicht finanzierbar ist
haben sie mir vereinigung war eigentlich
der sie haben im bezirk kann im prinzip
stimmt es ja auch der finanzminister
sagt ja zu recht der staat kann ich
alles abfedern
das ist völlig richtig
aber machen sie dann den leuten auch
wirklich klar was es heißt wenn das
nicht möglich ist wir leben eigentlich
in einer zeit der vollkasko mentalität
unter andere auch durch 16 jahre immer
mal wieder große koalition ein bisschen
mitgeprägt die leute erwarten sicherheit
jetzt gutes einem steueraufkommen der
hilft mir der kann das jetzt nicht der
kann ich 100 milliarden mal für die
bundeswehr locker machen was dringend
notwendig ist damit die mal wer täglich
wird der kann nicht alles andere auch
noch abfedern ich wette mit ihnen wenn
sie die klare brutale wahrheit sagen den
bürgern dann ist das mit der zustimmung
zu viel nicht mehr so dolle
aber sie müssen sich ja damals war ok wo
ich bei ihnen bin wir müssen es sozial
abfedern also ich meine diese wir haben
nach dem kriege das weiß kaum jemand wir
haben nach dem ausgleich gehabt ja wir
haben übrigens besitzenden haben die
hälfte abgegeben das befremdlich kredite
jetzt nicht dafür aber wir kommen eine
situation wo wir ganz andere lasten
verkauft er bauen sie haben die
russischen verbrechen gehen sie kennen
das bestimmt auch vom leider ganz
wahrscheinlich auch unterbrechungen wir
haben nur ganz kurz und dann sind wir
gleichauf den jahre wir müssen natürlich
geld verdienen ist völlig unverdient
richtig wir sind gleich vier
rechtsvertretern auch nur noch einen
satz
stimmt ja aber so sagt
wir können alleine diskutieren
wir sind jetzt runter oder felix
das wären wahrscheinlich
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren sind für den nachtleben der
schlagen sein machen mein name zähler
so nicht
herr jörges retten das auto ist aber
niemand von den politischen parteien
traut sich zu sagen ja das wollen wir
einfach nur freiheit diese grün-roten
der darin führen hochtrabende debatten
über die rettung des weltklimas und um
die füße ruhen die ratten das thema ist
viel zu wichtig um es nur der afg zu
überlassen lasst den leuten noch mal den
spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
vertraulich sind der politik bei den
journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu führen
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig gut
auch das übrige anorak träger aus in
bewegung bringen ich habe meinen beifall
um eine sache immer bekommt wer kümmert
sich darum niemand
sprechen ganz einfach nicht wirklich
richtig ist die komödie nicht mehr
glauben nur noch vier tore
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zurück meine damen
und herren und wir kommen jetzt direkt
zu der these von ihnen herr baum darüber
möchten sie heute mit uns sprechen was
sie bewegt sie haben einen antrag
gestellt eine strafanzeige gestellt
ja wir haben einen in sorgfältiger
vorbereitung eine umfangreiche
strafanzeige gegen die kriegsverbrecher
in der ukraine also die russischen
kriegsverbrecher gestellt und zwar
angefangen von der staatsspitze bis zu
der kfd kommandoebene das ist eine
ausarbeitung von 130 seiten für den
generalbundesanwalt und in dieser
ausarbeitung sind die einzelnen fälle
stellvertretend dargestellt die wir
kennen mario pohl und
beschießung von vor allen dingen von
zivilen einrichtungen die
zivilbevölkerung anzugreifen ist ein
kriegsverbrecher übrigens haben die
russen auch zwei arbeitende
reaktorblöcke in der ukraine gezielt
beschossen
das muss sich mal vorstellen was das
bedeutet werden dort radioaktivität
austritt aber wir haben uns konzentriert
auf zwei tatbestände kriegsverbrechen
und verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
und diese verbrechen sind gegenstand
eines deutschen rechts das
völkerstrafgesetzbuch sieht das vor seit
2002 und wir wollen jetzt praktisch die
waffe des rechts auch einsetzt wir haben
zwar internationalen gerichtshof der
tätig ist aber wir sind deutscher wir
haben deutsches recht und wir wollen das
jetzt in den krieg hinein die signale
gesetzt würden werden das den menschen
die dort täter werden auch deutlich
macht dass sie täter sind und das
bedeutet also dass der
generalbundesanwalt anfangen muss und
das tut er ja auch schon zu ermitteln
beweise zu sammeln
hier bekommt er von der flüchtlinge
bekommt einen nachrichten dieses bekommt
davon den engine aus und er bekommt sie
auch von uns wir haben namenslisten
hunderte von lahmt bis auf die
kommandoebene wir wissen also wie ein
buddha verantwortlich war und wir wissen
auch dass es ein gezielter angriff wie
auch andere gezielte angriffe auf die 2
die zivilbevölkerung
in geplant sind also keine spontan
reaktion
der während der so der soldaten übrigens
auch tschetschenen und die gruppe
partner steht bei uns das ist eine
solche truppe steht bei uns in der
strafanzeige also alles wir wollen ein
signal setzten ihr kommt nicht davon ihr
seid täter und nicht verjährt und mit
dem ziel
einigen die vielleicht sich überlegen ob
sie damit machen und sich für ihn
deutlich zu machen dass sie sich
strafbar machen und zwar in erheblicher
weise kriegsverbrechen lebenslang
mitunter je nachdem und wir haben das
völkerstrafgesetzbuch funktioniert der
generalbundesanwalt hat in den letzten
in der letzten zeit syrische täter
angeklagt die von deutschen gerichten
vorteile sind also das ist eine
möglichkeit in den krieg hinein zu
wirken der uns sehr lange beschäftigen
wird ich warne vor optimismus wir sind
im april sind im grunde schon mittendrin
ich möchte mal wissen ob unsere grenzen
unverletzt bleiben ich möchte mal wissen
ob die russen nicht in georgien oder
moldawien wenn weitergehen denn putin
lebt in einer andern welt er kommt
unserer mehr bekommt man eine
vorstellung er kämpft gegen eine
gottlose
dekadente reiche
erretten das russische seele und das ist
ein religiös auch untermauern das heißt
nützlichkeit argumente wie wir sie haben
pragmatismus erreicht ihn nicht mehr und
ich sage ihnen er macht weiter alles was
wir jetzt hören mit waffenstillstand
nicht kommt wir werden im hohen maße
heraus gefordert sein und wir werden
lange auch unserer gesellschaft damit
leben müssen wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen ich habe immer wieder gesagt
wir brauchen eine george hill raider
blut schweiß und tränen ist vielleicht
ein bisschen dramatisch 1900
1941 hat er seinem volk gesagt ich es
kommen düstere zeiten stellt euch darauf
ein und darum dass ein bisschen ab
das recht in stellung gebracht gegen das
recht des stärkeren
er brauche ich würde ganz hervorragend
begrüßenswerte initiative ich glaube wir
haben mit dem völkerstrafgesetzbuch eine
hübsche einzigartige rechts quelle die
kaum ein anderes land hat indem wir eben
auch wirklich außerhalb des territoriums
der saft hat eben täter verurteilen kann
das haben wir gemacht wie sie eben
dargestellt haben und ich find's ganz
wichtig dass wir jetzt an einem
scheidepunkt wo unsere völker
rechtsordnung auf dem prüfstand steht
bleiben wir bei dieser ordnung die wir
uns gemeinsam als wettgemacht haben
sollten nach 19 45 erarbeitet haben
bleiben wir dort geben wir diese in
irgendeiner form auf oder erreichen wenn
sie auf sie dort sagen der schlag mit
aller härte zurück muss klar sein jeder
einzelne soldat wird vor gericht
gestellt jeder kommando wird vor gericht
gestellt nach einer gerechten bestrafung
zugeführt also ich da sind ganz
essentieller punkt auch unserer
strategie das muss so sein ich will
nicht so viel sagen ich habe eine frage
herr baum eigentlich auch eine
informative wenn ich richtig informiert
bin unterscheidet man ja immer gerne
zwischen kriegsverbrechen und man die
individuelle tat verfolgt und dem
genozid der politisch angeordnet wird
was ist das aldi ist das in uhren
kriegsverbrechen oder ist dass das
vernichtung eines volkes also das ist
jetzt wenn sie das für rüstung auf den
punkt bringen kommt es in die nähe eines
genozids ist aber keiner da das muss
noch viel intensiver sein sage ich
leider es reicht ja schon die
kriegsverbrechen und die bereichen gegen
die menschlichkeit reichen ja schon um
das ziel zu haben sie bei
kriegsverbrechen immer die individuelle
tat so habe ich dabei gelernt ein
straftäter
und das ist natürlich schwierig oder
machen sie das ganze weil sie hoffen
dass sie wenigstens mal kommandeure
wirklich vor den internationalen
streitkräfte sind nach
möglichkeit auch solche
muss ich den täter
ist ein völkermord ist haben wir den
täter
ja na gut der wird auch die gerade dem
strafgerichtshof stellen aber wissen sie
nämlich das abschreckt nein dann wären
dann kann ich ja auch zu machen kann ich
sagen weil das ich nicht stellt mache
ich nichts der ist immun als
staatsoberhaupt wissen sie haben mir nur
sowie zwar auch immun und lea und happy
moschee und hinter nein dass das ist
kann nicht das kriterium sagt aus seiner
mannschaft auf diesen verbrecherischen
sicherheitsrat sind ex leute nicht immun
ja also das also wenn betriebe
völkermord ist es hier im eigentlichen
sinne noch nicht aber es ist ein
verbotener angriffskrieg sieben jahre
nichts verstehen mich in einem punkt
wenn sie sagen sie machen das unter
anderem um deutlich zu machen dass wir
diese brutalen taten alle genau
registrieren unter sachen so ist und
immer auch wieder transportieren die
öffentlichkeit damit vielleicht auch
doch mal irgendetwas bei russischen
soldaten bleibt sagen das kann ich nicht
mitmachen dann finde ich das ein völlig
tolles ziel ich glaube sie mit dürfen
nicht so sehr bei der öffentlich keine
ahnung am morgen können wir pro team vom
gerichtshof ich glaube doch nicht immer
gut
so also welt fern bin ich auch nicht
aber das muss es klar sein dieser mann
ist ein kriegsverbrecher oder gar nicht
noch eine persönliche frage stellen
bevor wir zum thema dann auch von incomm
herald sie haben bei frau maischberger
gesagt die kriegsbilder die ich jetzt
von putins überfall aus der ukraine sind
meine eigenen krieges wieder ihr großes
engagement
dass sie sich jetzt so sehr auch dafür
einsetzen ist als auch aufgrund ihrer
vergangenheit geprägt dass ich das jetzt
so zu ihrer mission machen also ich kann
mich in die leute hinein versetzen ich
habe das die zerstörung dresdens erlebt
in einer nach bombenangriffe und und
artilleriebeschuss auf weder während
meiner flucht reise mit meiner mutter
also ich kann euch ich war flüchtling
mit zwei koffern wie ich sie jetzt am
bahnhof hier in berlin sehe also ich
kann mich in diese situation
hineinversetzen und
ich kann mich auch an die traumatisieren
automatisierungs situation dieser
menschen hineinversetzen
aber da hätte das ist
das hängt mit meinem mann im leben
zusammen und ich bin ich hab ja die
vorstellung gehabt das kommt nie wieder
verstehen sie immer in der un charta ist
der erste satz wir wollen die menschheit
von der geißel des krieges befreit so
haben wir angefangen und nach den beiden
schrecklichen kriegen und in der
allgemeinen erklärung der menschenrechte
steht diese taten des vorigen
jahrhunderts haben das gewissen der
menschheit zutiefst verletzt das
gewissen der menschen hat wird jetzt
wieder zutiefst verletzt der ganzen
menschheit nicht nur nicht nur unsere
aber wir sind in besonderer weise
betroffen und wir kommen ja schritt und
für schritt für schritt immer immer
weiter in den krieg hinein was gestern
der stoltenberg gesagt hat hat mich
nochmal bestätigt das wird eine lange
schmerzhafte verlustreiche sache auch
für uns ein sehr schöner übergang und
danke auch für ihre emotionalen worte zu
ihnen was wir jetzt eigentlich auch tun
müssen in den nächsten ja in der
nächsten zeit und ich denke da gibt es
zwei positive nachrichten aus der
bundeswehr in dieser woche und zwar zum
einen wurde die debatte um die
bewaffnung von drohen beendet jeron tp
ich bin selber ausgebildeter tactical
operator war sechsmal im auslandseinsatz
und bin ganz ganz froh dass soldaten
jetzt besser geschützt werden wenn sie
im einsatz unter feuer stehen und dass
die dort eben nicht mehr warten müssen
bis ein kampfflugzeug kommt sondern mit
wirksamer luftaufklärung und bei bedarf
eben auch mit dem effekt einer bombe auf
deutsch gesagt unterstützt werden können
das haben wir beschlossen und ich denke
mal viele tote könnten auch vielleicht
noch leben die gefallen sind in den
auslandseinsätzen wenn wir das früher
gehabt hätte und der zweite punkt der
mich freut ist heute hat der
haushaltsausschuss beschlossen 2,4
milliarden zur verfügung zu stellen auf
antrag der ministerin bis 2025 komplette
persönliche schutzausstattung und
ausrüstung der bundeswehr zu erneuern
das heißt es geht um 305.000
schutzwesten über 150.000 neue kampf
kleidungs setzte und über 120.000 helmer
und rucksäcke also es geht darum dass
soldaten sicherer und besser
auszustatten im inland und im ausland
ist der erste schritt quasi zu einer
besser ausgestatteten bundeswehr und ich
denke mal das zeigt auch
handlungsfähigkeit überfällig längst
über für ja gut aber jetzt auch nicht
sagen nein ich kann das so bin ich
gescheitert in der 07 diesmal dielitz
drei unterhaltungen haben in einer wende
meine eine frage an sie herr reid ist es
berührt sie ja auch sie haben ja auch
geschrieben dass etwas auf einem auch
mit dem drohen was wir selber sehr
berührt weil sie da auch ein eigenes
erlebnis eigentlich haben oder damit
verbinden mit der schlechten ausstattung
ja es war vor zwölf jahren also im april
2010 nach dem karfreitags gefechten ich
war junger zugführer leutnant aus der
uni in meiner ersten verwendung und ich
durfte mit meinem zug die drei
gefallenen kameraden der karfreitags
gefechte beerdigen musste die beerdigung
das ist ein tag den ich wirklich nie
vergessen werde und ich hab das gestern
im ausschuss auch gesagt dass ich wenn
ich mir jetzt überlegen diese debatte
die wir geführt haben 13 jahre die dazu
geführt dass soldaten eben nicht optimal
geschützt wurden wir hätten schützen
können dass das dass wir das bitte in
gedanken haben sollen wenn wir solche
entscheidungen fällen und dass ich immer
an diese drei kameraden denken dass sie
dort gefallen sind wirklich
spiegelbildlich für viele viele andere
die dort ihr leben gelassen haben kann
es eigentlich sein dass wir in den
ganzen jahren egal in welcher partei
eine pazifismus debatte geführt haben
die wir irgendwie nicht zu ende gedacht
haben nach der schönen devise nie wieder
krieg das habe ich immer so
interpretiert nie wieder krieg von
deutschen boden sprich als deutschen
angriffskrieg dass hier das was wir zwei
mal gemacht haben
und
war es dann also falsch zu sagen wir
binden wir kümmern uns auch nicht um
andere sachen wir müssen uns nicht
verteidigen und greift ja wohl keiner
mehr an ist also der pazifismus
überdehnt worden und haben wir da nicht
auch wenn ich viel zeit verloren und wir
hätten das was jetzt passiert natürlich
auch schon in den letzten jahren tun
muss und dass die bundeswehr nicht also
im grunde wieder mal nur bedingt
abwehrbereit war wie schon einmal vor
vielen jahrzehnten als er selbst der
spiegel -herausgeber ins gefängnis
musste das gilt ja jetzt wieder nur
jetzt regen nicht so aufs passt die
jetzt in die landschaft also der bremer
wir beide waren ja in einer diskussion
unserer partei über den nato
doppelbeschluss ja die der damals auch
zum sturz von schmückt
beigetragen hat weil die spd nicht mehr
wir müssen uns wenn sie dass unsere
aufarbeitung jetzt der letzten jahre
erwähnen wir müssen unsere verhältnisse
sondern hast du mal klären die wird ja
immer so als eine feindselige dieser
sache angesehen auch von den deutschen
als ob sie uns bedroht die natur bedroht
ich glaube wer ohne nato hätten wir
keine wiedervereinigung groß hat sie
sollten ja auch die zwei prozent
einheiten ist halt etwas machen wir auch
hier wird die drohnen bundesadler das
was er da gesagt hat auch wirklich jetzt
ein held ist ein kleiner baustein die
drogengeschichte aberglaube die herr
bremer die interne und externe
wahrnehmung ist bei uns sehr
unterschiedlich also wie sie das
beschrieben haben dieser pazifismus in
deutschland nie wieder krieg was er sehr
wichtig und berechtigt war ich glaube
wir müssen jetzt immer mehr unserer
rolle in europa gerecht werden als
bevölkerungsreichstes land als stärkste
volkswirtschaft oder sind ganz andere
erwartungen auch an uns gerichtet mit
dem wir selber gar nicht so gut klar
kommen mit unserer bevölkerung ich
glaube daran müssen wir uns gewöhnen
dass wir jetzt ja auch das volle bündel
nehmen und eben keine scheckbuch
diplomatie in den 80er jahren betreibe
und unsere vergangenheit verpflichten
uns geradezu bedrängten demokratien zu
helfen
vor allen dingen starten die von uns in
schlimmster weise opfer geworden sind
die osteuropäischen staaten also den sie
zu helfen im hinblick auf unsere
vergangenheit ist ja absurd nicht zu
helfen ja ist ja absurd
trotzdem muss ich dann ein bisschen
nicht widersprechen unbedingt aber doch
einen kleinen einwand machen das ist
richtig was sie sagen dann bauen wir was
rechtfertigt nicht die in meinen augen
unsäglichen auftritte des ukrainischen
botschaft dass der hier
als ob das als opfer hin hatte herrn
steinmeier behandelt also nicht mal was
für sage es wieder anders sehen wir
lassen uns rechts links ohrfeigen ob wir
gute argumente haben zu sagen was sie
wollen geht so nicht es geht erstens
nicht dass wir jede wärmelieferung über
die bild zeitung in einzelheiten genau
verkünden auch den weg möglich zu
erkennen damit sie rechtzeitig
torpediert werden können es geht nicht
dass wir überhaupt liebe ein thema das
nunmal geheimhaltungs bedürftiger gutes
in ordnung aber die
haben ja auch ich hatte doch bestellung
der ukraine
es scheint ja doch lange zeit gedauert
haben bis mehr geliefert wurde also das
ist jetzt so schön darzustellen ist ja
nicht so also jetzt zieht man den druck
ob diese wirklichen schrecklichen
gräueltaten und ich bin auch froh dass
man jetzt mehr machen möchte aber es hat
ja ewig gedauert also wir haben auch
erlebt und der botschafter hat uns schon
vorher da hat uns ja auch der wusste ja
schon dass der angriff kommt ihr habt ja
gibt mir den und geprügelt und jetzt
gebe ich ihnen recht er ist sozusagen
nicht diplomatisch korrekt und es
gefällt wird vom 2 aber es ist wahr und
jetzt verstehe ich und erkennt um sein
land erkennt und seine leute die sterben
wie die fliegen und erkämpft und das
recht ich glaube dass er sein handeln
jeder am tisch aber ich würde gerne noch
mal auf herr bremer zurückkommen ich
glaube da ein uns beide etwas ich habe
als herr wenig hier auch bei uns im
studio war ihm auch zwei drei kritische
fragen gestellt auch wieder wollte ich
auch glaube ab und an und das haben sie
ja auch gerade gesagt ist es ja auch die
vor wie man etwas ruhe bringt die
verzweiflung versteht ja jeder aber was
stört sie genau an dem botschafter die
art und weise wie er sich im grunde auch
auf führt als habe er zu bestimmen was
wir zu machen aber er gibt uns ein ganz
schlechtes gewissen dass wir nicht die
ganze bundeswehr gleich los schicken ob
wir haben doch gezögert wir haben ein
bier wurden doch zum jagen getragen in
einigen haben das auch so eins dieser
urteile die schnell fahren wir wurden
immer zum jagen getragen vielleicht hat
man sich darauf zu recht vernünftig
überlegt wir haben eine konstellation
auch in dieser koalition
wo das was jetzt scholz durch gesetze
überhaupt noch nicht in trockenen
tüchern ist bin mal sehr gespannt ob das
so einfach läuft bei den stimmungslagen
bei den grünen in der spd wo der
pazifismus immer noch da ist die sind
jetzt unter schockstarre
weil sie der scholz überrollt hat aber
das dauert das gibt bundestagsbeschluss
hat bin ich immer sehr gespannt die
grünen fangen noch an nicht nur für
grabner kodex lag dass das alles denn
das ist alles gerade keine basis in
trockenen tüchern aber
welche rennen will ich gar nicht gut die
grünen das ist nicht immer wird auch die
union bei uns sein denn ich glaube nicht
dass die union sagen wird wir stimmen
100 milliarden für die bundeswehr nicht
so einfach warum nicht heute haben sagte
ich nicht zugestimmt haben ihren eigenen
kanzler stürzen
mir wäre es lieber weil das ist die
typische scholz blase ja ewig verhindern
weil man ja das geld hier etwas anders
ein witz und dann kommt 100 milliarden
der bundestag ist man sich nicht einig
also ich möchte einfach nur sagen das
ist eine typische staat 100 auf einmal
ein bisschen natürlich froh dass wir
endlich was kriegen deshalb wird es
weitgehend auch mitmachen aber viel
wichtiger ist dass die kontinuierlichen
2 prozent das ist wie gesagt hey auf
einmal alles raus und in kenia wieder
veraltet leiden das ist das richtige und
dadurch ihn jetzt zum schluss schon
nicht mehr jetzt zu der nur noch von den
100 milliarden reden und die zwei
prozent sind schon verschluckt das
stimmt ja auch das ist wieder
unterschreiten nicht dass da immer man
seine verpflichtungen erfüllt und dass
auch die bevölkerung versteht und da
gebe ich ihnen völlig recht herr bremer
das natürlich auch bereit sein muss um
abschreckung abschreckende wirkung zu
entfalten das ist leider auch
erforderlich weil es nicht so sind nicht
alle menschen gut so sehr sich das immer
alle menschen das war der letzte punkt
für die sendung heute abend ich bedanke
mich sehr wohl beim ein gästen es war
lebendig ist war leidenschaftlich ist
war sehr gegensätzliche meinungen ich
bin mir sicher wir haben rübergebracht
was will man film nachts wollen und zwar
die lust am debattieren betten auch mal
mit menschen zu die partie die nicht
dieselbe meinung haben und werden wir
werden sie mögen dann sehen wir uns
dienstagabend wieder hierbei bildschön
abend wünsche ich ihnen auch tschüss und
vielen dank an alle mädels
[Musik]